Betty that is not how an adult from
hacks what are you doing with the
Constitution oh I signed that not have
done mash there's some tricky stuff
about black people in there just playing
somewhere safe to keep it hey it's your
birth certificate says that you're
adopted what that means your mother and
father are auntie your mother and father
in poop poop that means that Lillian and
Hortense aren't your sisters oh wait
who's what ins neither is Beatrice
having sex with a stranger my whole life
Beatrice isn't your sister that means
you didn't commit incest yes I
understand what it means you don't have
to rub it in no it's a good thing there
is no scandal you're just a regular
adulterer it's a good thing if everyone
in Washington cheats on their wives and
vice versa
what we'll announce the good news right
after the Olympics I want the fame I
want the whole world to know my name
this